chris
uh james also asked us to address the uh
uh i don't know what you call it it's a
clip of or not it's not a video clip
it's a little
short written piece on a cashless
society
uh that's going that's gone viral on the
internet that says i wrote it and i
didn't write it oh
um so um like it's all about conspiracy
theories and there's going to be no cash
and the cash is you know
all the digital is going to be used to
track you and um you know put a put the
mark of the beast on you or whatever i
don't know what the crap it is but i
mean
if you read like one paragraph of the
thing you know that i didn't write it
because i'm not crazy
right that helps here's the other thing
interesting that we live in a culture
today
that is more tech savvy
and has the ability to access
information so many different ways
through all kinds of social media and
yet
people believe anything
so the they're tech savvy and yet
they're stupid that's exactly right
yes i mean so i've been i've just been
retweeting
uh i did not write this in quotes
everything on the internet is true abe
lincoln
[Laughter]
it'll come to you think about it but um
yeah so no i did not write the cashless
society crap that's going around
and uh just come on people yeah
think don't retweet and facebook is
worse because it's i guess there's more
stupid people on facebook i don't know
but
it's like uh twitter's twitter's hate
facebook is dumb
can i just go on from there but um but
yeah just
think when you look at something go i
don't really think that the president
said that
i don't really think that so-and-so said
that i'm not going to retweet it until i
actually think about this and look at it
and check it
it's like i like dave ramsey says we're
going cashless dave ramsey didn't say
anything about it
it's it's absurd now here's the reality
would businesses love for us to go
cashless
absolutely they would we've seen time
and time again studies show that when
people use
plastic they spend more yeah okay we
know this
18 to 20 percent more so businesses
would love for that to happen
uh i've read in a few articles that some
businesses have run into
not having coins so they didn't have
change so they were encouraging people
to use their debit cards
uh but you know i'm with you dave people
will take these things and just run it
together and
and crazy can attract more crazy and the
next thing you know is you got the
snowball
well my theory is as long as there's
rednecks there'll be cash
the cash isn't going anywhere because
i'm always going to have
some hundred dollar bills yeah i mean
that my my three
100 bills folded over in the back of my
money clip is my redneck emergency fund
and i've had one for 30 years three
just well that's all that's in the back
oh okay in the back yeah
i don't touch that because you've tossed
me your wallet well yeah i got a money
clip i carry real cash you have real
money in there but that's
not the point i'm not bragging about
that my point is that guys like me
are always going to have some money me
too money
me too uh you're never sometimes that
stupid plastic the algorithm kicks in
because of identity theft and you can't
use any of it
i've had that happen yeah i mean where
they could not take it they actually
dave ramsey and not being able to check
into a hotel your debit card that'll
piss you off
okay so yeah you got to have some cash
right there i mean it's just you
geez no no i did not stupid
cashless thing yes just settle down
settle
spread that out there among your stupid
friends
unbelievable retweet that
repost that on facebook